i mr. wonderful here and welcome to
another episode of ask mr. wonderful now
you know what I love to do time to time
is to invite a guest on onto the show to
help me answer all of your questions and
I'm always amazed by how many questions
we get and where we get them from all
around the world let me tell you about
this special guest for this week I think
you're really going to enjoy her Maria
Sharapova she won Wimbledon when she was
17 she's renowned all around the world
as a tennis star really to win Wimbledon
at that age obviously sets you apart
from your peers and it's a remarkable
time to become world famous but there's
many many athletes out there that have
achieved great things and I respect all
of them and they do deals they endorse
products and services but very very few
ever become operators in business they
use their name to to you know help
products but to actually operate a
business that's really hard to do and I
met Maria on the set of Shark Tank
she came on as a guest and I was really
impressed I mean you know I cut the
guest sharks a lot of slack but once we
get going into deals they're just
another competitor she was sharp she was
very sharp I learned later that she's
actually a CEO I thought that she'd
endorsed a sugar company or a
confectionary company called sugar
Povich she just lent her name to it no
no no no she's the CEO she's the
operator she deals with it takes up 70%
of a day and that is really hard to do
so that's when I I said okay this is
different this is not the typical
athlete this is someone who made the
transition to entrepreneurship and then
into business leadership and all the
trials and tribulations associated with
running a company it's hard to do it's
it's hard on a good day to do it
and let alone all the challenges retails
having today at etc so it's wonderful to
bring her on to the show I think you're
gonna really enjoy her insights her
sharp tank experience and of course
answering your questions alright let's
go
here we go with Maria
oh yeah how are ya just I'm just setting
up the cameras on the in front of there
in one second okay where are you in
length no like I'm in Miami okay it's a
ghost down here I'm same here I'm not
surprised
what a mess would you go in walks or
what's your I've been pretty freaked out
so I haven't done anything yet I just
took the liberty of a bicycle alright
I'm gonna take the cruise because I'm
really getting out of my mind I've been
here ten days now all right I'm doing
all the television stuff remotely mostly
with zoom like you know networks are
using zoom now I think Damon and I are
doing in Morning America hey you got a
train you got to turn your camera okay
oh you've got the background and
everything yeah listen you got it you
got to jazz it up a little bit do you
really do yeah that's it
well yours looks sort of Nouveau kind of
architectural you know yeah Maria so
glad to have you on the show
really appreciate it I have to ask you
but I've got lots well I've got
questions from all around the world
which I want you to answer we're gonna
get to those but there's a few things I
want to ask you about right now your
shark tank experience I mean first of
all what got you into business because
come on you're a professional athlete
very few of them are successful in
business yeah there's a few but not many
they never get the training because
their youth has spent you know learning
their craft as an athlete when did you
make that transition so I think as an
athlete I was always very scared of
being one-dimensional because from a
very young age what I did was very
one-dimensional my craft was very
singular I always had horse blinders on
it was just one way right I would wake
up I would train for hours and I would
already be thinking about the next day
and the next tournament and although
that was my path and I loved that
I love competing I was always aware of
the fact that tennis wasn't just a sport
that it was a business and little by
little as I started working with blue
chip brands whether it was Nike or a tag
heuer or Evian I started learning like
the education process you know at first
as part of advertisements then I started
working on the creative then it was the
marketing and as I was going through
these paths meeting different people I
realized that I wanted a little bit more
decision-making I didn't just want to be
like a face of something or a brand
using my name so we went into those big
those big contracts were coming in what
age were you I was a teenager
your kite yes I won Wimbledon when I was
17 and that's when I I knew I knew that
tennis I had this theory that it was
more than just a sport but after that I
realized that there is a lot of business
involved so once you win Wimbledon that
is brand right there for the rest of
your life because zero percent of the
population point zero zero zero zero one
ever get near that and there you win it
at 17 remarkable brands start
approaching you're saying look you know
start endorsing us your agent obviously
is working those deals for you the world
didn't really know you till then they
didn't know what your personality was
they didn't know if you were nuts if you
were crazy well the first thing I'd say
is my family moved to the United States
from Russia with $700 so at that point
when contracts were coming in and I was
being paid to be the face of a brand it
was very exciting right it was it gave
us a financial freedom to travel around
the world and not be dependent on that
money maybe from from a sponsorship or
from an IMG which was managing me and
has been from that time it really gave
us like just a little bit more freedom
as I started accumulating those years of
being you know top 5 in the world it
certainly brought me the financial
security and from that point on
deal-making and the strategy behind
deal-making became very different
because instead of just being a face I
actually had an opportunity to be an
investor
and that's when I really started
understanding business you know what
what a VC is you know who's mr.
wonderful who's putting in that money
and I actually grew up watching shark
tank because my business mind started
rolling and part of my education was
while I was on the road and getting
treatments and massage at the end of
practice or a match I'd be on my
computer watching those shows in the
background so my mind was always was
always turning a lot of a lot of people
want to be on Shark Tank but you know to
be frank with you the producers want
investors they want people that
understand the process of evaluating a
deal valuations structure all that stuff
which is why most athletes don't get on
shark tank somewhere along the way you
convince them that you really were an
investor and I must be honest with you
and I don't say this all the time you
were pretty good on Shark Tank you were
impressive because you you weren't and I
wanted to ask you at that experience
because you actually said no to people
and most guests don't have the guts or
the the cojones to do that they want to
be nice to everybody but you were really
not so nice which I really liked
so talk to me about the experience all
the questions I have half of them are
ask her what it was like to be on Shark
Tank to tell us about the process how
did what happens cuz we don't know and
sharks what how they bring you in you
just show up one day and then we said we
should we shake your hand well it starts
a long way out I think before we shot
the episode I I went into a meeting with
the producers and the editors and Sony's
and and basically was interviewed for
the job they were trying to figure out
if you had the chops right if you
understood yeah and I think it was
everyone that's on the show you you have
to have a feeling that not only do you
love the show but you're part of the
show and so he's more like to even know
what the show is about because I can
imagine that maybe some don't and I I
knew the ins and outs oh I knew I was
okay on that I was a slightly worried on
some like the technical business terms
but I I surprised myself on the
like in the show I felt like I I knew
most of it what I loved about the show
is how real it gelled I I think we had
eight pitches that day and at the end of
the day it was like cotton I was like
wait I want more look good keep going
but I want to I want to let you in a
little secret man just so you know this
after the niceties are over when when
you come in you take your seat
about five minutes later we don't give a
[ __ ] about you anymore for yourself it's
alright I think it makes it real because
it is and I think it's important for the
person that's trying to sell their deal
that they understand you're engaged
which you work I wanted to ask you a
back to your professional career you
recently retired for tennis and and I've
got a plethora of questions and
basically the theme of them is this when
do you know it's your time it's about
how do you know if your whole life has
been you know won Wimbledon have been a
professional known globally your brand
is known all around the world it must be
a [ __ ] to make that call it really is
and it was it was one of the most
difficult decisions I've had to make and
for a few reasons one because a huge
part of me all of me like still loves
the sport and loves playing and it was
it was really my escape and no matter
what was happening in my life whether it
was good it was bad it was medium I
would go on the court and all those
thoughts would disappear
I wouldn't think about anything but
being in the present right because I
wasn't in the present I would have
performed well I wouldn't feel good but
it was time for my body and I think my
my body made that decision in the last
couple of years was a real struggle for
my shoulder and getting to a tournament
and stepping out on the court felt like
a victory and I've been doing this for
way too long to feel like that was a
victory I wanted the victory to be
holding trophies and that was that's
always been my competitive edge and
that's when the body was like this is
this it's almost not fun right because
you train and you were
love the work and effort you're putting
that in to go and get through the
quarters and the finals and work worked
your way through your body in your mind
and I wasn't able to to do that anymore
today if you're if you're moving up
you've got that fan base you're building
a brand you're creating value it's it's
it's got a dark side but it also has a
huge benefit doesn't it
I prefer building a brand by being a
champion so if anyone gives me that
choice I prefer the results and doing
the work and not talking about the work
to be to be your pillar and now you have
both options which i think is is is
beneficial and building a brand is a
very you know it in today's world in
society it can mean so many things it
can mean something that's slightly phony
unless you make it really authentic but
the true value of an athlete and the
Corps is very much result-oriented
because that is sport right it's it's
emotional and it's entertaining but at
the end of the day it's win or lose and
in tennis because it's so individual
there's a match point there's that and
there's so much more to it and the
feeling of winning is unlike anything
that you can experience in another
profession which is the beauty of it all
right let's start some questions I've
got questions from all around the world
they're interested in your insights
let's go to the first one here this is
Katie listen to Katie I'm sure you can
hear her so because all roads lead back
to mr. wonderful I can't tell I watched
Shark Tank a lot I want to ask you about
how to help smaller businesses my
husband and I came up with a proposal
but because we aren't in business yet we
were hoping you could offer us some
words of wisdom
I keep hearing stories every day about
businesses that are closing their doors
because they don't have the cash
reserves to handle a crisis of this
magnitude and even if we get stimulus
checks it won't help businesses as
people avoid public places like
bookstores and restaurants so the
businesses that are able to get loans I
wonder if that would be
to carry them through especially because
I don't believe that spending is going
to skyrocket once life goes back to
normal
relatively speaking in America consumer
spending accounted for roughly 58
percent of the GDP last year and I think
it's safe to say that that's not going
to happen this year in the GDP will
shrink do you have any thoughts as to
how we can try to cope businesses on a
larger scale other than buying discards
Morean is a bunch of questions in there
but this is really - this is a very
intuitive series of questions because
obviously there's an entrepreneur in a
Katy somewhere but she's really scared
in this current environment let's start
with the the back end where she said do
you think it'll be the same ever again
for for retail for consumers buying
behaviors what do you think is gonna
happen with this whole virus thing and I
think hopefully be doing in the next few
unless we're in full quarantine as we
cook a meal or two at home breakfast and
dinner but lunch we do we pick up so all
the restaurants that are in our
community that we've ate at four years
with my family and my friends we pick up
and I that's how I've been trying to
support them I live by the beach I'm
driving up Pacific Coast Highway I've
been going to Felix a couple of times a
week it's one of my favorite restaurants
the chef he's there seven days a week
right now doing pickup and take away so
I've been trying to support as much as I
can there's a local coffee shop that I'm
getting gift certificates for so I'm
trying to play my part but I'm utilizing
this time to to really spend with my
family let's get a question here from
Steve listen to this one thanks for
taking the time to take my question I'm
in from Ireland ten years ago on set up
a tea company six years ago the first
few years were very tough and they
challenged me however if you look I'm in
a bit of limbo now and my sales are
between 200 and 300 thousand a year with
a net margin of about 70% however I just
don't feel challenged as much anymore
and aggravate
five hundred thousand in cash in the
bank in the business and I happily live
off the modest paycheck that I pay
myself and so everything runs quite
easily I'm a one-man band and I don't
have to put a lot of time into the
business anymore
so things are good but they're not great
I just don't know what to do next I do
put and I do put all free cash buy do I
put all my free cash back into the
business or do I start something else
and I know I don't have enough to fully
retire or relax to be secure about my
future but it seems like the businesses
just find its place and runs as is
what's your advice on my next move also
after reading a book I'm wondering if
you ever made it to Ireland oh yeah
here's a guy on his own used obviously
did a direct-to-consumer business has
half a million dollars in the bank and
he's bored first thing you need a shift
in the attitude just by listening to
that voice note I feel like there's no
spark there's no energy you're not proud
of what you're creating you're not
excited about what you're doing in order
to make something great it you need the
steps toward greatness and that starts
with the attitude that you have so no
matter what you're doing no matter how
much money it's getting you you've got
to love it
right there's gonna be the ups and downs
and you're gonna go through all the
challenges and you're not gonna love it
all the time but you have to be excited
about building something you'd agree
yeah I totally agree I'm quite amazed
because you know although the hard work
his studies created a business it's it's
generating a living he's I got half a
million bucks in retained earnings like
there are million people that would die
for that opportunity that never get that
success he I totally agree with you he's
got a really look himself in the mirror
and say I've got to motivate myself or
do something else I mean he could do
something else obviously successful I'll
answer the last part of his question yes
Steve I got to Ireland to visit my
father's grave in Malachi and what an
experience that was there's not a lot of
room for anybody be buried there
anymore so it was a really small
gravesite but it was wonderful to go
back to the homeland but thanks for that
question 70% I mean it's it's it's
phenomenal I'm just I'm licking my chops
thinking myself maybe I should buy the
business off him it's ridiculous it's
crazy all right we have another one here
this is from Alex let's here Alex here
we go people often say that if they just
had more money they would work less and
yet I've noticed that a lot of extremely
wealthy people work many many many hours
sometimes even more hours than they did
before they became rich why is that if
there was ever a question for you Maria
this is it I mean what what mate what
would motivate you after you're filthy
rich to work having the passion and
being curious to know how much more to
which level I could take it to how much
better could I get is that it is there
more in me I tried retiring I retired
for three years and I visited every
beach on earth I decided that was my
mandate I wanted to try it the ones in
Vietnam was a Cambodia all these
beautiful places and I was bored
shitless
I was just couldn't believe how boring
that is and how meaningless and listless
you become I just want to be in the game
I just want to compete I mean I don't
need more money I want to keep what I
have obviously but but I like to compete
and I you know it kind of it's a full
circle back to shark tank I see myself
and those people on the carpet as I'm
sure you see some of when you were
watching them they remind you of earlier
years when you had that hunger and you
didn't have anything yet and you want to
help them sometimes if the valuations
right you know it's perfect but it's
kind of like it's a great question to
end on because that is the motivation of
life it's it's the pursue
something that gives you meaning and you
know for you you got to answer this now
tennis is over what's going to be the
new Maria what are you gonna do for the
next 10 years what's the game plan for
you well I've been running a candy
company for six seven years now so I'm
no but we all know it sure right
so I've I'm in the day-to-day of it I'm
in the in the daily decisions I'm on
conference calls for the last two weeks
six to eight hours a day with teens with
manufacturers retailers that are some of
the ones that are going through the
tough challenges right now so I'm in it
I'm the CEO and and running the entire
business so that that takes a majority
of my time I love architecture actually
so that's a passion of mine and I'm
breaking ground on a really cool health
and wellness project in a few months so
there's a few things that I'm certainly
passionate about but there's very
business-oriented so sugar promise 60%
of your day would you say 70 probably
well then let's drill and do that just a
little bit before we go retail retail I
mean you know I I just had twenty-two of
my companies on a zoom yesterday talking
about the complete collapse of retail
revenue sugar palm you have a lot of
sales in retail right what's that what
are you gonna do what's the game plan
well because candy and sweets and snacks
is very much probably like an 86 percent
impulse purchase so we're relying on
someone going to the stores for their
rice or for something else and picking
up the packaging on their way out or a
checkout so that's how that that's how
our category works not that's not good
news Maria that's not good yes we
haven't seen a drop in sales in the last
month which which is a good sign but who
knows what's gonna happen
retailers are closed they're closed now
there's zero traffic well I sent of the
ones that were it are still are still
open right so the grocery some of the
grocery stuff oh you're you're you're in
this you're in the
channels where their necessity the food
channels right the food channels right
how are you ever lucky right so the one
that's taken a huge hit is Hudson News
which is an airport store where in over
five hundred stores across the nation so
that's taken a huge hit that's one of
our largest accounts so I'd say when if
someone is in that position such as I am
it goes back to there's nothing you can
do right now alright there's nothing
what you can do is make it personal
because we're all in this together you
call up the people that are working
there you understand their problems you
figure out how you can help
just this week we we did a little social
media campaign called a little act of
kindness we sent a hundred boxes to so a
friend could nominate their their
parents or their other friends or
doctors or nurses that are on the front
lines of all of this so we just sent out
a hundred free packages to hospitals all
around the country so it's doing little
things like this yes we're losing a huge
account at the moment but we'll get that
back people are gonna travel again I
have full confidence in that we have to
make sure we have the right inventory at
the right time and working with all
these retailers on a much personal level
because as we all know this is a time
where that we're all in this together
yeah thank you so much for your time
today incredible insights what a
transition athlete to CEO I mean look I
don't get pressed very often but I'm
impressed Thanks it was absolutely
wonderful thank you
Lucy yes yes I'm I'm hoping we'll see
you there that's terrific
take care hi where do you think an
episode well you know that your episode
was up forty percent you're over weird
yeah it's pretty interesting what's
going on Jason I'm on show in America on
Fridays now so let me just start
recording this
oh it is recording okay good we're all
set then all right
take my glasses off everything seems to
be working so fast so good yeah you know
I just miss a checklist at all this
shipment has to be on my cleat
one last adjustment
I wanna see that wall head
to the brain
[Music]